[Applause]
alright enough my friends another week
another departure from the White House I
haven't seen this many quick exit since
compote Lee served that bad meat I
survived this administration has had
more lineup changes than Van Halen if
Sammy Hagar becomes chief of staff I am
out it was no David Lee Roth now it's
Rex who gets xed there is major breaking
news this morning from the Trump
administration just moments ago the
president announced that Rex Tillerson
is out as Secretary of State
Houston would be more accurate here to
be replaced by the current head of the
CIA Mike Pompeo I'm sad I for one loved
the guy he had the voice of Sam Elliot
and the sturdy body of John Goodman he
seemed like the kind of dude who could
change a tire with his bare hands and
crush a can of apps on your forehead
while doing single arm curls using a fat
teenager but here's some advice Rex
don't do Celebrity Big Brother in fact
don't do any reality shows especially
naked and afraid I want to remember you
the way you were
[Music]
see what I mean now his replacement is
Mike Pompeo and Pompey's replacement is
Gena Haspel say what you want about this
pair
they ain't Aussie and Harriet judging by
the media's frazzled of fearful response
it's more like Bonnie and Hitler should
her tenure at the CIA overseeing for
that period of time the controversial
torture program should that be a black
mark on her there have been many public
stories linking her to torture there's
not much else that we know in terms of
behind closed doors stuff from Mike
Pompeo his time at CIA when he has had
to speak publicly sometimes he's said
things about Russia that are completely
untrue not I have a golden rule if your
chief complaint is that these people are
too hard on terrorists not a complaint I
listen to
that's why cause that's what I call it
asset to be treasured
so go screw yourself know these two in
my opinion these two seem perfect
together they're like a fearsome
tag-team in the world's most unstable
octagon earth it'll be the most exciting
confirmation hearing ever sunday sunday
sunday get ready to go undercover and
over-the-top as the creators of the
white house rumble extravaganza Brazil
confirmation and dilation Dominique move
over intelligence because it's Gina
Hinata guys five hostile as she joins
forces with Mike the super potato Pompeo
greatest tag team since Sultan and
together they're making America safer
than a silhouette germaphobe full
clothed they won't even say the word
espionage because it sounds too fresh
plus the first 100 people who arrive get
a free siren on capsule and there's no
need to sign up because they already
know your personal information it's the
confirmation annihilation domination
[Music]
so we know the grippe they're saying
that ask that the woman here tortured
but that's only an opinion and one
that's off the mark turns out the most
repeated accusations levied at Haspel
had to be retracted but really anything
can be torture especially to people who
think running out of kale guacamole at
Whole Foods is agony and so I ask those
who think enhanced interrogation is evil
what's your alternative
seriously what replacement do you have
for waterboarding let me guess
[Music]
I agree that is worse than waterboarding
bottom line if you got to make a
terrorist talk in order to save lives
then everything should be on the table
including thumbs toes and noses a lot of
media critics have the luxury of not
having to face such dilemmas no in their
shiny studios they parrot the same old
pointless phrase but we're better than
that well I'm not I am what's called a
bad person
terrible even the media however acts as
if getting down in the street with your
enemy only makes these terrorists hate
you more sorry I can't see how they
could do worse to us than 9/11 yeah sure
Isis wished we'd stuck to the high
ground because then they'd still be
creating selfie sticks out of Westerners
heads so if we hurt their feelings or
their faces so what for once let's
proudly and loudly say we're not better
than that because under Trump it seems
to be working we didn't lower the bar we
remove the damn thing good stuffs
happening all right
if you must then by all means say we're
better than that
while the Patriots who think otherwise
continue to save your ass she's so smart
she left the view well he's so sharp
that ninjas throw him at their enemies
watching The Times opinion editor Fox
News contributor Shirley hurts so good
[Applause]
her favorite beverage is a kittens tears
natural review reporter a captive infer
tyrants ready to quip and shoot from the
hip writer and comedian Chris free
alright Jedediah welcome back to Fox
News I have a very important question
the view who had the worst breath come
on you're probably me because I used to
be eat right before the show so I
probably what a cop-out
we know Edwards had bad breath I mean a
full question you know you could ask a
really inventive question there I'm just
gonna say breath
somebody works at ABC for years give me
advice true I used to eat cheese and
cheese flavored things right before I
went on and it was actually a paranoia I
had because the person next to me I used
to always say does my breath stink and
sometimes they say you know just after
this tough smell it yeah you're right
it's disgusting all right let's talk
about the topic at hand everybody
starting about chaos jaw the job changes
everything going in and going out is it
as bad as it seems
or there's a bunch of media hysteria
media hysteria I mean I think this
happens every administration that you
talk about there's people that shuffle
in and out I think I think the issue is
here obviously is that it's Donald Trump
and everyone is waiting for mostly in
the media waiting for like the next you
know bread crumb to fall so that they
can pick on it I do think that some of
these picks are a little weird for him
though like honestly when I was looking
at this he ran
as a guy who was kind of a
non-interventionist kind of guy that's
what I liked about him because I'm a
libertarian I don't want us a nation
building over there and changing up
leadership and now he's picking these
really hawkish people it's interesting I
bolted in him are not on the right page
saying hey even even that this lady with
the waterboarding like like
waterboarding or not me she seems very
hawkish to me this doesn't fit the brand
I don't think she ever waterboarded
anyone I don't I think that I think she
did the ProPublica had to retract a lot
of things Charles that they said that
she had done Charles do you have a
choice choose your adventure you could
talk about the confirmation hearings
how's that gonna be what we're stormy
day well you can talk about stormy
Daniels if you like I do it stormy
Daniels I do yeah go ahead
no no what were you what no word of my
options I'm confirmation hearings is it
good are these guys gonna sail home oh
no this is what what first of all Donald
Trump he picks these people that that
are in disagreement with him yet he gets
clobbered in the media for being
somebody who only surrounds himself by
yes-men and the evidence for that are
all of the know men that he surrounds
himself yes
and so the guy can't win either way and
and I and I agree with you is the media
just makes this stuff up but one of the
things that I think Donald Trump has
always been so brilliant about the guy
he is so good at picking the right
fights at the right time and this is the
best fight to pick with by you know by
having confirmation hearings for
Secretary of State and your director of
the CIA as we're going into IND into
talks with a militant nuclear nation
that wants to erase us for the and
Democrats who think well we don't like
this event we don't haven't gotten all
the transient and Americans could be
like shut up yeah yeah yeah it sure
they're gonna speed it through cat I
know you love enhanced interrogation so
you're very this is a breath of fresh
air for you
I agree with Jedediah I'm also a
libertarian and I don't like to see all
these hawkish people going in it's not
just the torture stuff it's also Mike
Pompeo he's very supportive of
unconstitutional spying through the NSA
which I'm for but you like I said I'm a
bad person which I'm not for which is
why Greg gave me that wonderful question
I would like to see people around him
that are non interventionist I think
that we waste so much money in so many
lives overseas doing things that we
don't have any business doing in the
first place and the government also
doesn't have any business spying on me
unconstitutional you don't nobody spying
on you like a conundrum to me because
you are used when I used to talk to you
about politics you were a small
government guy right when it comes to
this national security stuff or
waterboarding or NSA it's like bring the
government in spy on everybody
okay look at my hands okay this is
security and this is freedom they do not
fight they hold hands
[Applause]
no they do whole dance they're like
siblings who just go a little too far
apart iris yeah anyway no Chris
were you surprised were you surprised
that Tillerson was fired are you
surprised that a trump is just doesn't
care no that's not surprising you know
I'm more surprised I don't I don't have
a reaction to the torture thing I don't
like so back when she was doing that it
was kinda legal or I don't know yes
legal or just don't ask hey tell ORS I
don't whatever it was they did it and
then the rules changed so she probably
won't do a legal stuff so you know in
the NFL like before they used to not
have as many helmet-to-helmet rules yeah
and then when they change that they
didn't fire all the players because they
think so you play by the rules
does it bother anybody that she the
allegation is that she wanted to destroy
those tapes of the waterboy I think I I
think there that's not entirely true but
if that if that were true I mean a lot
of tapes I want to destroy but we've all
been yelling that's probably true but
we've all been yelling about Hillary
Clinton for how long that they took a
jackhammer to the old devices like there
we don't want we're destroying evidence
and transparency that's a great
transition because we are gonna be
talking about Hillary and the next block
nobody learned something at the view I
wanted to talk about stormy Daniels mom
the fact that she said that she if
Donald Trump should keep running and she
would vote for him every time so I
really this is the first time the mother
of a porn star is proud of what her
daughter did which was Donald Trump